[Music]
how's my man
oh what no play huh
i really hope you're happy there
i'm working on something to bring you
back
they've never managed to connect a
computer to the archives before
i waited a long time and then i saw
something
we had a visit from the archive company
the subject is elmo julie alice term
time so far two years eight months four
days
she's not ready to go yet of course they
think your robots might be based around
their technology
we are obliged to act with force if
necessary
you made another like me i'm not
replacing you
but you did it what was she like
she was perfect i want to go home
this is home
girls can hear me
do not let her outside under any
circumstances
i have to try and get her back i am
shutting you down immediately
what do they want they want you
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learned
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one
[Music]
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're taking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it future
i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go
that was a terrible crash
[Music]
we're lucky to be alive
stop don't come any closer it's a girl
oh my gosh girl i'm sorry blonde hair
i've just never seen a girl before
who are you
it's so loud here we call it the noise
happened to all the men on this planet
and we thought in our heads
we're on display
where are all the women
the dead
why is she thinking where the hell is
her noise it's strange to see everything
you're thinking you know it's strange
for me too not knowing what's going on
in your head
i mean i know you might not like my dog
or you want to hit me over the head with
a rock or something
i like your dog
those men catch you they'll kill you
if you want to protect the girl you have
to leave now
with her power there's no telling what
he can do
i need that girl before she wants him
come in here coming 100
200 thousands
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all i have for you is a word
tell it it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
use it carefully
[Music]
to do what i do i need some idea of the
threat we face
as i understand it we're trying to
prevent world war iii
i'm not saying i'm getting here no
something worse
i gather you have an interest in
time travel no inversion
aim it and pull the trigger
you're not shooting the bullet you're
catching it
what i've seen too much well we'll try
and keep up
your duty transcends national interests
this is about survival
it seems bold hold on i'm fine with that
we're going to say nuts
this is where our wheels collide
how would you like to die old
you chose the wrong profession
[Music]
well happen here hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
we need a tenant we need to save them
here and now
it's reversing the flow of time
it wasn't us being here now and it never
happened
[Music]
you want to crash a plane we're not from
the air no it's so dramatic
well how big a plane
that part is a little dramatic
many homes have the pretence of being
ideal
but these homes really are ideal
it's not exactly what we're looking for
[Music]
wait no no i don't think this is the
right way yeah this is the way we came
in
no is it did we just do some kind of
loop
hello
i've never heard such silence
what if they don't come
what are we supposed to do
this house is forever the perfect
environment for a young family
people like to be alone sometimes not be
with each other
all the time
just gotta have a bottom this is
something i could do please just let me
do this
i want to go home
that's nature that's just the way things
are
this is our only chance
we have to take
[Music]
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
there is something provoking him that
we're not seeing here the same opinion
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last ones standing
no one
deaths continue to spiral out of control
due to the oxygen crisis that the world
has termed the sickness
last year i had 20 kids in my class this
year i have 12.
ethan what do you know what your father
did here
made the chronicle what if i told you
that you could save all of us
save your wife we received a message
from the future in the future this is a
phone machine the people who sent the
message
must have found a cure do you really
believe i'm going to save the world
you're all men you may be humanity's
only chance
to finally cure 10 9
8 7 6
5 4 3
2 1.
come back to me
whoever sent the message we need to find
it
we are at the beginning of the journey
that can change everything
you have to trust me now this isn't that
funny
[Music]
imagine that we are all connected by the
very fabric of the universe
[Music]
[Applause]
an invisible field that bonds us
together here
me the stars we can't change anything
it's always going to play out this way
there is no other way we are all
connected through time about saving the
world
and initiate sequences
what is this i'm sorry to be the one to
tell you this but you
got yourself killed at rsd
we'd rebuild the most important assets
in the u.s military soldiers like
yourself
you're the first who we've successfully
managed to bring back
improved enhanced with the technology in
your veins
you have an army inside you that will
not only make you stronger
it will heal you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
where are you going i gotta finish
business
oh that's not good
all right set him down
and initiate sequence
[Music]
okay who is the next target for
elimination
do you remember anything do i know you
guys i don't think so
i've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes i ain't
an initiate sequence
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
[Music]
i feel like i just heard this are they
playing this on repeat
it's 20 years since the moon was hit
electricity for only an hour a day
barely any food and all you care about
is cozmo
attention unregistered teleportation
his power is unbelievable beyond
anything i have seen
all we have is now i like you
[Music]
i waited for this stepping in here makes
everyone nervous
fear not the game is more dangerous than
it may seem
all the hardships earth faced are a
result of the war with cherno
we're about to go play football with
what's essentially a nuclear bomb
and everyone else thinks this is just a
game is that right
pretty much it yes
it's easier to risk your life when you
know you're supported by millions
even if they don't know the truth or
understand the risk
four young earthlings with incredible
powers
you show there is something to be
inspired by here we go
yulia can you tell me why you decided to
help the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
do i have to answer they're back again
you you're in danger
you all went too far in your research we
have to get out of here
you can come back
but she must be eliminated so this is a
cyber attack but not from this planet
you know i don't belong here dad
everything's gonna be fine
i don't even have a passport are we
gonna cross the border we'll have to
cook up a corruption scam
no more cell phones no more digital
[Music]
technology
[Music]
help me
[Music]
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his
a
life
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it fake
call it lock
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
are we there yet this beach it's
beautiful
my swimsuit is hurting they do look
small come on let's play hide and seek
have you seen my children mom i'm right
here
he was six years old this morning oh no
mom i'm scared there's something wrong
with this beach we were chosen for a
reason
what's happening
oh only in theaters this summer
[Music]
good evening
[Music]
oh wait you're just a civilian now
mr james ford general ryan's requesting
your
inimitable counsel no
he's offered to reinstate you
from the top four hours ago the crew the
vander made first contact
stay there
in the event of first contact humanity
must strike first
to ensure the continued survival
of our species operation cosmic sin
is now a go about there because of space
gate
they can bring their army here
what's the status of the cuba if we want
to launch the cue bomb
we need to get into orbit suit's up
that's something huh we didn't know
whether to burn it we put in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me
if we leave that door open we're gonna
charge in
we can make this the kill box
i'm not gonna wait for them to bring the
fight to us
we're gonna take it to them what we do
here
is easy
the hard part is living with it
[Music]
what is kepler teaches louise
we will not think about ourselves
we will not let our emotions guide us
we do this for the many
she was called mother earth
we plundered everything she offered
all reproductive efforts fail for both
men and women
they want to prove that we can procreate
here
survivors
why are you following me i want to help
you
[Music]
we waited so long i'm so pleased that
you're here with us now
it's imperative now that we bring our
people
[Music]
are they coming
[Music]
the human race doesn't need us to
survive
are you still with us blake
none of us should have come back
am i dead you're in a
you coma all of this is a dream
memories everyone in a coma goes to the
same common space
[Music]
here in coma some people develop unique
abilities
in order to discover those abilities a
person needs a little push
to be put in danger i'm wondering what
your special ability is going to be
the man from the balcony is he the
leader
he taught us how to survive we're here
for a reason
everyone who's here didn't make it in
reality
they didn't have a future there
you haven't figured out anything yet
have you
i'm the commander here
this world is made of memories
how did they get here get down there's
an island
free of reapers somewhere in the coma
we're always looking for people who can
help us get there
is this my life now i remember that i
couldn't be together with who i wanted
to be
here it's possible
our world would never appreciate
something unusual even if it's a hundred
times better
what do you need reality for after that
we need to wake
up you can't wake up
do you understand your body is there in
coma you are here
there's nothing you can do about it life
in coma is as real as it gets
i said hold it
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you're the gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
what's happening i went from time
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
in an overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
go fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up doc
[Music]
when your wives suggested couples
therapy do you think
this is what they had in mind definitely
i mean we're a couple of couples right
bill ted enough of the delusions you
didn't time travel
and you didn't go to heaven and hell
here's a real idea for you be role
models to your daughters
get real jobs
[Music]
bill we've spent our whole life trying
to unite the world
and i'm tired dude dad we have a destiny
to fulfill
oh wow greetings my excellent friends
we have a problem
step forward a song created by preston
logan
performed tonight we'll save reality as
we know it
oh dude we better write that song now
why can't we just go to the future when
we have written
take it from ourselves except won't that
be stealing
cheers how is that stealing
we're stealing it from ourselves dude
[Music]
dude our dads are totally in
you should help trouble out
[Applause]
no way how's it going ted
we're putting together your most
extraordinary band
hey you want to be in our band
oh this is your fantastic we're going to
go talk to death
is he playing scotch by himself dude
he's
cheating hey death
[Music]
let's rock
excellent to each other and party on
oops
[Music]
how you doing well you know dead and
we're in hell
but how you doing
tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband he renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Music]
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than us
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or shall i just stay
dug and come but my plan was to drive us
away
glare your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
i made my choice
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
[Applause]
[Music]
we're dropping a secret team of robots
into a country that we're not supposed
to be in
it got serious the moment was thought up
gotta get out of here
take them all down no witnesses
this is not a circus we need to know
what the hell is going on here
what do you want
[Music]
[Music]
you're
train derailed to cross the highway if
you are carrying this broadcast
seek shelter immediately you think it is
no idea
oh my god
the only thing people want to talk about
today is this interstellar comet called
clark
nasa's saying it appeared out of nowhere
from like a different solar system
this is the fragment entering the lower
atmosphere three
two one an impact where's the explosion
it's a chunk of rock rocks don't explode
yeah tell that to the dinosaurs
the sky's on fire come on let's go
with the largest fragment expected to
hit in less than 24 hours
space agencies are expecting an
extinction-level event
the greatest chance of survival there
are the funkers in greenland
we're gonna go gotta go now okay
[Music]
you're such a brave guy
pg-13 on demand everywhere december 18th
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
here you are standing on the precipice
of something so much bigger than anyone
here
but always remember you are not alone i
don't think that we met i'm sarah
niles hi high
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
good day so far today tomorrow it's all
the same you
what is going on hey get out of the
water
i guess you followed me it's one of
those infinite time loop situations you
might have heard about
that i might have heard about yeah
[Music]
the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start i drove all the
way back home
to austin and i still woke up here one
time i smoked a bunch of crystal and
made it all the way to equatorial guinea
it was a huge waste of time
well then what's the point of flipping
we kind of have no choice but to live
no i'm gonna get out of this suit
yourself
see you tomorrow
so now what do we do you just have to
embrace the fact that nothing matters do
you sleep with people in here great
question
i have but it takes a lot of work yeah i
got in
it's the first dance and that's a deal
breaker that didn't work
let's waste some time
[Music]
you're right got him
[Music]
everything that we are doing is
meaningless
i hope it's not all meaningless at least
you have each other nothing worse than
going through this [ __ ] alone
stop there's a bomb in the cake don't
worry i used to be a bomb guy
stand back
[Music]
[Music]
there she is guess what
daddy is going to get you dressed for
school today
we are descendants of the gods
this land was always ours but we must
never relent
or nowhere and everywhere
you're from virginia right i can tell
you're special we are the future
[Music]
you you're not like the others
whoever you were before
that's over
[Music]
what are we doing what is
the plan
[Applause]
tonight 9-1-1
what is your emergency
look at this all those years in the big
city we finally got out
we're living the dream maybe
it is a dream
[Music]
then everything just blew up
big flash like a pink light or actually
i don't even know what color it was it
wasn't like any color i'd ever seen
before
looks like a meteorite
is radioactive i mean it's from space
right meteorites are generally no more
dangerous than ordinary rocks
how can something that pink just
disappear did you plant those
no wart come here for a sec
oh god what are you doing
it's talking to me who's talking to you
a man
[Music]
it's in the static it's in the moisture
it's in here is out there
and what's out there is in here now
everything's under control
oh i hear you so in denial that thing
from the meteorite
changes everything around it
[Music]
it's just a color
can you believe me now i don't know what
i believe anymore
everything's gonna be a-okay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
huh
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
video
can anyone
your father is no longer of use to us
you have something we want
do you think this is a game way we
should
sorry we're out of time
i've kept everything you can do hidden
hoping to prevent them from finding you
what am i
everything you need to know is in
[Applause]
to stop here
wake up
[Music]
listen carefully you are now five
thousand miles from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
this
foreign
for scale from one to ten how bad bad's
my rig
i drilled to the bottom of the ocean and
we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how
we're just gonna walk with insufficient
oxygen across the bottom of the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
i was deaf
there's something following us
under water
[Applause]
you have any idea what those markers are
they look pretty ancient
the tracks in here definitely bravo team
they don't just disappear
where the hell are we that lightning it
hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
guys so what
are we like guardians of the galaxy now
on our six
yeah bros
holy sh
did you see that thing
this is officially above my pay grade
i don't care what those creatures are
you destroy them and close the gateway
i'm getting us all home
right
today the 18th of march 1965
the manned spaceship fosscote 2
was launched into the earth's orbit
for the first time in the history of
mankind a man has walked in outer space
i don't understand the pressure in the
suit keeps increasing
[Music]
[Music]
okay
are you suggesting that i leave them in
orbit they're soldiers they're prepared
to die to protect their country's
interests
will daddy be here when i wake up again
he'll do his very best
[Music]
good morning miss garcia good morning
sunshine
i miss you i could kiss you right now
sunday curfew is now in effect
all unauthorized citizens must stay
indoors
tensions rise as we enter the 213th week
of lockdown the grim new reality emerges
23 has mutated beginning thermal scan
thermal scan normally a horrifying new
development new data
all infected americans are being forced
into quarantine camps
[Music]
department of sanitation sarah talk to
me i think my neighbor has a fever it'll
be so much easier if you just open the
door
mrs grant you have visitors
sarah do not open that door
[Music]
detected armed guards will be arriving
in four to six hours
you must not attempt to leave your home
or you will be shot on
[Applause]
my site to you i know you're in there
they're coming i have to let you go
no no no no sir say goodbye sarah i'm
not letting you give up
sometimes we have to do things we don't
want
to survive i'm trying to save the one
person left in my life
that matters to me
i can't help you what you're talking
about is illegal
[Music]
and remember stay safe save and sanitize
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time
rain i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend
iliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
and makes you live through it until it
kills you
who's there
we can get out of this together
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
the time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
look like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
this is captain max cloud do you read
[Music]
over
okay then who wants the first dance
max cloud is here
uh dad playing those damn games
[Music]
can i touch you
pull yourself together soldier we don't
have time for this
what beer is not near cowboy is
here i'm pretty sure i'm in the game
i'm kind of freaking out right now so
look out
[Music]
literally no one was shouting
you were fantastic
these are sharks but they can fly
you say
outmasher between paris and leo no
flying fish stands between me and my
passengers
put the skies and the martial law it's
the only way that we can be safe
yeah that's what i like to see
[Music]
you